if you boil dogs alive and you pay
children a dollar 25 or 325 a day if you
allow women to be beaten or they require
four witnesses for rape do we don't need
to listen to you you don't get a seat at
the International bargaining table let's
talk about this right now everything
wrong with China and not just as a part
of this pandemic right now right but I
think if nothing else is sort of lifted
the veil for a lot of people to realize
like hey as far as international trade
goes as far as the agreements they're
not necessarily our friends in every
country doesn't necessarily enemies I
don't want to be Aleutian you should be
American by American I mean have you
have you driven a volt have a triple-a
in Japan these are my card so point is
now that I said that we can dump on
China so Donald Trump has been trying to
sound the alarm particularly as it
relates to international trade on China
for quite some time
I'd like to have you take a look at the
fentanyl that's coming out of China and
Mexico major Chinese drug traffickers
Ford the strip and they have really put
very very strong clamps on them they've
indicted them when well most HIV % for a
car to go in and we charge 2% for their
car to come into the United States
that's not good we've tax China on three
hundred billion dollars worth of goods
and products being sold into our country
he said he was going to stop fentanyl
from coming into our country it's all
coming out of China now I just think Ida
and I've talked about this I don't like
the idea of tariffs because that's a tax
passed on to the consumer however right
there is a valid point when you do have
countries in it and it's no longer
equitable if they are taxing our goods
going over right as more Libertines we
have we agree like listen we shouldn't
be just putting a tariff on to punish a
country but right if they are punishing
us we really is
a fair international trade agreement and
I think and no one no one by the way
Bernie Sanders talked about this Hillary
the Clintons talked about this a long
time ago I know NAFTA we can go nibble
Klim but if you listen to Hillary
Clinton's rhetoric but certainly Bernie
Sanders Donald Trump's the first person
to do anything as it relates to trade
that's not what we're talking about
today but it has sort of fostered an
environment with this festering pustule
that has become the Chinese communist
government China this week they reopened
the wet markets that were allegedly the
source of this and by the way they're
still selling bats dogs and cats and I
want to be clear and I try to be really
careful by the way I want to warn you
we're not showing anything graphic as
far as videos but to me it's still
disturbing it's really hard for me to do
any of the animal stuff so yeah let me
describe it for you and then tell you
you're not going to see anything other
than dogs and cages at the market okay
what markets allegedly for what we
understand create a virus and now while
the rest of the world is still going
through the pandemic they reinstated
them to understand the severity that
imagine the United States removing all
the social distancing guidelines and
then banning soap that's how severe
bring back the wet markets can be no
hygiene standards the cruelty though is
it's over the top dogs are kept in
cramped cages and then I'm not going to
show it but then they're boiled alive I
want to warn you it's not graphic but
the following footage will make you
angry
[Music]
we had to cut it short because now we
can join without you guys are getting
super super pissed yeah no bill what
does wet market mean I don't mean to ask
you do and you're asking the Asian half
so it'll be okay yeah accurate so so
what people have always understood what
markets to be and what they've always
been described as is the wet refers to
the blood people are going to be
scanning the animals alive or butchering
them live on the street in front of the
customers and they like wet work a
military term you know assassinations
and that's how thing it refers to the
blood that's involved but now actually
people are trying to swing the other way
to try to counter the racism of just the
facts of the situation of how these wet
markets exist there was an LA Times
article came out either today or
yesterday that tried to say well it's
not actually referring to the blood in
the butchering it's just referring to
the fact that they host the ground off
and the ground is wet wet with the blood
of the animals that were killed alive
because apparently that makes them more
delicious yeah
lest you think that these wet markets
exist in the countryside because you
think oh it's got to be removed no the
Wu Han area where these wet market it's
a fifteen million person City right
center it's like you get in downtown New
York right right around everybody that's
packed together so it's not like an
isolated thing out in the country
right-o to know and just so you know the
numbers I mean it's tens of thousands of
markets oh yeah market I mean and at its
peak before they started shutting them
all down which was not long ago months
ago writing about there were tens of
thousands of these markets and even in
not just in the quote-unquote rural
provinces which is a good point Gerald I
mean these are multiple million person
cities but even in Shanghai or Beijing
or in the suburbs around those towns
they have those wet markets and you know
it's again it's not just the idea of a
butcher right like we have butchers here
and they do live butchering but it's the
proximity of wild animals all together
will combined with the hygiene and the
mixing that creates the huge problem
that right here yeah so let's have some
points here that I think that matter in
in relation to China in half Asian built
you can half correct me where I'm wrong
the white markets they're not only where
coronavirus started also SARS yeah let's
let's be clear about that
and those are just the diseases that
originated specifically in the wet
market so all meant not all but many
different strains of bird flu
okay swine flu they spread in these
markets they didn't they weren't created
necessarily ins markets but this is
where they spread he's and they led to
repeated outbreak they've shut down
these markets during they shut him down
during the SARS outbreak during the age
seven and nine which I don't necessarily
remember it was that was we knew about
birds that's what we knew about bird flu
that was a pandemic it was and now
coronavirus so what's most important to
me is they shut them down right so this
disease spreads they shut down the wet
market I get Railly okay and then they
reopen them so they know that it's
happening there and right now it's extra
dickish because the pandemic is still
spreading across the globe and they are
already reopening them like can't you
wait until the bodies have assumed room
temperature in Italy in Spain in the
United States before you reopen what you
knowingly had as it created as an
incubator to create the proliferation of
this disease let's go down to some other
dangerous things that have been going
the research okay so if the wet markets
weren't bad enough Chinese government
they've been conducting all kinds of
viral research oh yeah right they've
been they isolated and worked with over
2,000 I wanna show ya over 2,000 new
viruses including bat coronaviruses just
three miles from the Wuhan market you
were saying actually some of them are of
1.2 kilometers 1.2 kilometers away what
a Washington Times put up there that it
was three but I actually just Google
Earth it but the Chinese government or
somebody from removed from Google the
listing of where that that's interesting
I would like to know why there's that
kind of strep and see I wonder if it's
the way of the bird no so one point is
use kilometers walking really walking
you can look it up right now well I
don't want to look it up right now I'm
saying like the people at home I'll
trust you over Washington yeah you
should definitely do that they're
they're researching viruses deadly
viruses call it three miles to be
generous now if it's 1.2 kilometers
that's about half a miles close how do
you like growing organic turnips next to
area 51
yeah that's not a good idea it's not a
good idea
my alien turnips and this isn't a race
thing it's a bad idea thing don't study
deadly viruses next to where people eat
live things yeah this is important we're
not just pointing out cruelty because we
don't like no cruelty actually does have
a dramatic effect on the health of these
animals in the immune system like people
or you want to talk about factory
farming United States that's why they
have to inject it with all kinds of
antibiotics because their close
proximity your dog is dirt your dog is
filthy enough they lick the crotch and
then try and lick your face like I get
it and kind of when it's your own dog
most people are fine with it I
understand but that's not what's
happening with these dogs when you put
them in a cage and they're basically
being abused their entire lives they are
going to be more fertile carriers for
disease and to give you just so you know
this isn't necessary everything that
you've all said here is reasonable and
now I'm starting to think yeah
biological warfare would never come but
in 2013 we wouldn't send Chinese
researchers they created a mutated
strain of the the bird flu and their
attempts to make this is this is quote
attempts to make strains in a lab that
would if accidentally released are used
for nefarious purposes pose a
potentially global health threat now I'm
saying they were a possibility they
weren't they weren't like playing it coy
like they were just saying that hey if
this were to happen it would be really
bad yeah and they were acknowledging
that we're doing all of these things
that hopefully this like have you seen
Jurassic Park 1 through 5 rife finds a
way well if you are not subscribed or
not joining my club despite mug Club
quarantine month hit all notifications
yeah
and of course subscriber credit bits we
have new videos that go up every night
at 9 p.m. Eastern anyway here on YouTube
so there's always a clip on YouTube get
the full show here's another thing that
I think is pretty important when we're
talking about China because the media is
not doing it they're carrying their
water I'll tell you why I think the
meteor come I think the media are
communist sympathisers I'm not gonna
walk that back at all right now
no but also go back to that because
unless you shut it off I just did
advertise colloidal silver and say that
they were economies let's get to the
masks the test kits that the equipment
right here's the thing there's been
they've not been honest we now know this
when it comes to medical testing right
with the corner
everyone is acknowledging that we were
throttled on YouTube for saying you
cannot trust the numbers coming out of
China right now we didn't say that they
are flat-out wrong but you can't trust
them no yet and of course YouTube
Twitter Facebook they decided to
redirect all of these kinds of
statements to more authoritative sources
some of which were directly from the
Chinese communist government come back
to them by the way Donald Trump said
we're not taking the masks everyone gave
him crap for the Netherlands yeah they
had to recall 600,000 Wow faulty masks
from China the latest test kits from
Spain they only worked 30 percent of the
time same for the kids Turkey yeah
country after they are scrambling to try
and dump some of these bad Chinese
products that are destroying the chances
of taking the coronavirus out or at
least containing it here think about
this for a second take all the numbers
from these countries and then add
potentially 30% yeah you're talking
about the infection rates yeah we're the
only country that doesn't have that
right now we have more accurate testing
right now
yeah and now we're doing more and more
testing by the day effect I was shocked
I had to double-check this and have read
your research a thirty percent failure
rate
that's insane what do you use a condom
with a 30 percent failure rate yeah 30
percent of the time that's what he's
saying so it's a 70% failure this is
what they had the only work 30% Chinese
I can't do math we'd be up in arms it
was 70% failure rates and the Chinese
government in Spain basically the
embassy said well they just they weren't
license to make the product so our bad
asbestos might want to avoid that for a
while the best by day not really
relevant it's all bad they do have a
history by the way of sometimes China
exporting goods that I was making sure
about that poisonous toothpaste yeah
that toxic children's toys yeah unsafe
tires all of which had to be recalled
now I want to be really clear not all
chai not all Chinese goods are bad and
not all American goods are good so and
by the way if there's an American
manufacturer out there who can actually
create a quality mug for us we would
love to
yeah work with you it just has to be at
a reasonable rate and decent quality at
that time we could only find American
Union maid mugs and it was more
expensive so we said we'll bring it in
from a company that tests chemically
tests they're there their products and
now we have Americans who are etching it
and painting it so creating more jobs
but if there is an American manufacturer
who can make this kind of a mug we would
love to partner with you yeah and if you
want a big old fat contract and mrs.
pandemic there are a lot of new mug club
sign up so thank all of you I pray to
God and I mean it that we see in armed
interaction from the Chinese people
against those commie bastards at some
point in their lifetime they got
overthrown are you encouraging violence
for the people who are being passed from
there because all of a sudden
disappeared whistleblowers right several
doctors now one tried to blow the
whistle on the mask she's gone yeah yeah
I think I think somebody will need to
defend themselves or and I think people
need to rise up and hopefully the
international community rather than
being paralyzed by political correctness
will say you know what you know what
these people not the government these
people deserve the same rights that we
have in France in Spain in Italy in the
United States so you know what Chinese
government because we sympathize with
your people how about that some some
point I would like we need to do that
I'd love to hear that press conference
here's another point no it was it's been
Miller Fenton all okay last night was
what the president said Fenton all I was
like oh he's a president I must be wrong
then I realized
not exactly the rate of fentanyl related
deaths been doubling every year now
almost 20,000 dying each year main
destination for vendo the united states
main source of fentanyl china now i know
and i know what you're thinking and this
is a valid point you have Americans who
make meth or synthesize opioids that's
absolutely true
but those people are not creating drugs
that are effectively sanctioned or
actually subsidized by the government
and given tax breaks on exports as you
see in China yeah yeah no that actually
happens for context just imagine Joe
exotic receiving a federal grant for a
gay meth tattoo parlor Tiger Den that's
what all season do it's not that
not that they're the only country with
drugs it's the government actually
subsidizing and giving tax breaks on
FanDuel is an export
fortunately President Trump on all these
points but hit particularly fentanyl as
he pronounced it he's been he's been
pretty consistent and I wish that more
people listened on all of these points
they taxed our goods going into China
it's a totally unfair deal we've tax
China on three hundred billion dollars
worth of goods and products being sold
into our country the Chinese virus it
comes from China yeah think about it for
a second why were Washington Post New
York Times Vox all saying the flu is
something should where the corona virus
is not an issue don't worry about it now
they tryna act like it's a left right
thing no no you guys said not to worry
about it because at that point you were
parroting the World Health Organization
talking points who by the way we're
pairing the Chinese government talking
points then all of a sudden when it was
blamed on the United States that we
weren't ready because we were trusting
information from China and a Chinese
foreign minister who by the way was not
throttled or censored by Twitter at all
but Laura Ingraham was for saying that
the masks were faulty which is true
actually no she was censored because the
chloroquine thing I think I was sensing
that foreign minister quickest Occam's
razor here why would they say it's not a
big deal and then all of a sudden say
it's a big deal and the right is wrong
about it for the same reason that they
don't seem to have a problem with
doctors and whistleblowers disappearing
in China and they refuse to run the
press briefings here in the United
States from the White House here's a new
rule while we're talking about freedom
of the press you know what it's not
exactly Communist China here if CNN
refuses to run the press briefing and
instead runs commentary on the press
briefing that you don't get a seat or a
press badge how about that how about
once you stop parroting Communist
Chinese talking points then maybe you
get a seat at that table it is
remarkable to me that I can't think of
any other time in American history but
orange man bad that we have a president
commander in chief who's going out there
addressing the people directly the
President of the United States and the
media is opting not to run it instead
running false propaganda
that maybe they're not getting from the
Chinese government but it certainly
would be congruent with the messages
that the Chinese government is trying to
put out there right now when you look at
reporters retweeting the Foreign
Minister with conspiracy theories for
some reason they're still on there but
Alex Jones is not this is the president
of the and something else it's
remarkable they go all potentially a
hundred thousand to two hundred twenty
thousand deaths from corona Biden
you know where you got those numbers
from Donald Trump's press briefing dummy
but you didn't run it because you didn't
want to include that we're getting
hundreds of thousands of new masks we're
getting hundreds of thousands of masks
that can be sanitized the FDA approved
the therapeutics that Donald Trump
touted and you said he was wrong and
crazy about so what do they do they
don't run the press briefing instead
they run commentary and the press
briefing while the Cuomo's talk about
their mom's pasta sauce and nipple rings
then they take the worst numbers from
the press briefings and don't actually
tell Americans about the positives
listen not all cultures are created
equal and don t it Donald Trump is right
about this just like Bernie Sanders was
right about this Americans should not
have to compete with the child at a Nike
factory who's working for a buck fifty a
day this is not we can't be at an
international economy if it's not fair
and you know what when we're talking
about this not all cultures are created
equal because I think that American
exceptionalism is a good thing and you
know if you if you boil dogs alive and
you pay children a dollar 25 or 325 a
day guess what you don't get a seat at
the International bargaining table and
not just China because not all cultures
are equal if you don't let your women
drive you don't get to sit and dictate
any policy or even express your opinion
here in the United States if you allow
women to be beaten or they require for
witnesses for rape do we don't need to
listen to you we're not going to be in
any committee or international agreement
that you take part in so let's start
with China and then work our way down so
that hopefully we can be the end Peyer
we've been accused of being and make the
rest of the world the United States of
America why because the Chinese and
everyone else would be better off I know
I got a little worked up there but their
videos playing in boxes here so click
those if you want to see more content
hit the subscription button or hit the
notification bell hit all notifications
so you'll know when new videos come out
but hint every weeknight at 9:00 p.m.
Eastern you can come
and see a video and I just want to
clarify I know I got passionate lest it
be misconstrued as racist I do not have
a problem in any way with the Chinese
people it's just the hats